اليوم ارتكبوا عملا ارهابيا جديدا جريمه
اخرى دخل المنطقه الحدوديه واطلقوا النار
على المدنيين
[موسيقى]
جزيره مرحبا بكم وسط تقدم روسي اللافت على
جبهه
مسلحه اوكرانيه باحتجاز عشرات الرهائن
بمقاطعه بريانس داخل روسيا وبوتين يصف
العمليه بانها هجوم ارهابي في حين نفت
اوكرانيا مسؤوليتها وقالت ان الهجوم
استمرار للتحول ضد بوتين في روسيا في
فلسطين اضراب شامل في اريحا احتجاجا على
محاصره قوات الاحتلال المدينه
واشنطن تصف دعوه وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
لمحو قريه حوار بغير المسؤوله في حين اكدت
المقرره الاماميه لحقوق الانسان للجزيره
انها ستحقق في استخدام اسرائيل مدنيين
فلسطينيين دروعا بشريا
تزامنا مع اضراب شامل يشل قطاع السكك
الحديديه في كامل الاراضي التونسيه
تنسيقيه الاحزاب الديمقراطيه تتهم الرئيس
قيس سعيد بالسيطره على القضاء وبالانقلاب
على مطالب الثوره واسعيد يقول ان كل من
اجرم في حق الشعب التونسي يجب ان لا يفلت
من المحاسبه
ارتفاعه الانبعاثات العالميه من الطاقه
التي تبلغ مستوى قياسيا جديد بلغ حوالي 37
مليار طن العمل الماضي وذلك على الرغم من
زياده التكنولوجيا نظيفه مثل الطاقه
الشمسيه والمركبات الكهربائيه التي ساعدت
في الحد من تاثير زياده استخدام الفحم
والنفط الى اللقاء